es gibt eine sache vor der jeder
youtuber angst hat oder sagen wir mal
jede person die irgendwie ein bisschen
bekannter ist und das ist dass die
eigene telefonnummer veröffentlicht wird
und ich habe jetzt vor einer gewissen
zeit mal probiert das ganze mit seinem
telefon scherz dienst zu machen das hat
irgendwie leider nicht funktioniert aber
ich wollte das wirklich irgendwie gerne
umsetzen dieses video falls irgendwie
auch im hintergrund schon sehen ich bin
nicht bei mir selbst aus sondern bei
meiner freundin der telefon scherz den
wir heute machen wird folgendermaßen
aussehen die schwester von meiner
freundin ist 13 und damit circa einem
alter wo man so ein junger fan sein
könnte von youtube aus diesem grund wird
sie von meinem handy aus bei den youtube
an anrufen so tun als hätte sie mein
handy genommen und dann den youtuber so
ein bisschen erpressen so verwegen
schwach schick mir das macht das für
mich sonst veröffentlicht ich deine
nummer es ist ein bisschen fies aber ich
glaube ich für ziemlich lustig wir
werden das selbstverständlich wieder
auflösen am ende und ja dann würde ich
sagen
rufen wir mal bei dem ersten starten wir
mal mit dem ersten opfer und elli komma
ins bild das ist heute unsere
telefonieren
wir beginnen jetzt mit einer person die
rallye auch selbst schon kennt und zwar
sebastian mein bruder der wird
wahrscheinlich am ehesten sagen okay
verarschen kann ich mich selbst aber ich
glaube es mir trotzdem lustig haben so
ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben
so einen kleinen liste mit möglichen
antworten oder sachen die sich sagen
kann aber ich denke mal definitiv dass
er nicht drauf reinfallen wird sebastian
ja du kannst ja einfach sagen
vielleicht erinnerte was sie sich nicht
mehr stimmen es klingelt jetzt weil
sebastian verbänden mein handy dafür
weil dieses bestimmt nicht daran gehen
würden
okay leute das starten schon mal gut
zweiter versuch bei patrick hallo bist
du wirklich pech ich bin eine freundin
von der kleinen schwester von
krankhafter bei der falschen nummer
angerufen läutet das war einfach die
alte nummer von patrick gerade ich hab
mich gewundert warum geht nicht so
schnell dran also geklärt so schnell
rein bin ja hier passiert ist ja
bekannterweise kein junges mädchen aber
wir probieren will helfen über probier's
mal bei der richtigen nummer ok diesmal
wirklich patrick hallo bist du wirklich
patrick ich bin ein freund von der
kleinen schwester von krankhafter ich
feiere deine videos so hart ja das lag
darum und weil ich da ich hab mir ist
einfach genommen
ja ich kenne ich halt von youtube und
ich mag deine videos und ich so sehr
aber ich glaube ich spreche jetzt direkt
eine nummer
ich geb deine nummer auch nicht weiter
wenn mich bitte in einem die ein in
einem video von der grüßt ja die junge
sechs junge mega perfekt okay wie gut
das funktioniert
du bist das erste opfer leider wird
natürlich nicht weitergegeben
das war die schwester von meiner
freundin richtig gut gespielt oder ja
ich muss mal ein wörtchen mitreden
es war richtig cool aber ich bin richtig
gut okay dann das funktioniert das video
gehört später hätte es auch verlinkt
alle frank opfer sind verlinkt wie gut
das war es war mega also video
improvisiert hassen sie ich hätte es ich
habe selbst fast glaubwürdig nebendran
saß richtig gut leute das ganze ist
übrigens auch so eine kleine antwort auf
die ganzen fake punks und sonstwas weil
ich mein so was finde ich wirklich
lustig so da steckt ein kleiner
überlegung hinter und es ist auch nicht
irgendwie beleidigend oder verletzung
für irgendjemanden und aus diesem grund
wird personal zwei jahren als nächstes
versuchen wir es
bei rewe mein gott hallo
die story doch ich erkläre es alleine
stimme klar oh mein gott ich feiere
deine videos so hart wo also ich hab
dich gib jedem seiner videos den daumen
hoch und um etwas ist so toll ich komme
speicher mir deine mama ab okay du hast
du glaubst es eh nicht
nein in einem versuch war richtig gut
gerade eben hat geklappt
nein aber eigentlich so du hast dadurch
dass du so so monoton geantwortet dass
unsere story kaputt gemacht eigentlich
ist die story dass die gerne mit ihr
gesprochen hat eine freundin von meiner
kleinen schwester ist mein handy
genommen hat so verstehst du dann wäre
es glaubwürdig gewinnen egal ob wir
probieren es weiter du kommst das video
und ich sag auch passiert ich abonnieren
sollen danke trotzdem lustig also der
musste direkt dass er verarscht wurde
die macht auch so selbst helfen
verarschen deshalb für rubys bei luca
luka mit dem hab ich sogar schon über
die video idee gesprochen wenn ihr jetzt
reinfeldt dann bleibt für mich kaputt
hallo ich bin ja ich bin eine freundin
von der kleinen schwester von
krankhafter
ich feiere seine videos und dich so hart
[Musik]
ich glaube ich war mit einem direkt ab
mayuka gewürzt ist direkt oder ich weiß
ich hab gedacht ich vergesse überfordert
ist oder so bei patrick hat sie direkten
klappt verriet als folge kaufte und so
ich glaube ich muss man wirklich mit
maxim von sury die lustig da wirklich
egal das video fall später wissen was
sagen wann kommt minecraft sehr einfach
aber präzise viel spaß gerade aber
richtig gute schauspielerin
ich hätte gern sogar fast gedacht uns
als luca bisher dann so gesagt hätte ich
gedacht ist er ist vielleicht sogar auch
glaubt ich bin keine anrufe sie okay
nächster versuch ich glaube vielleicht
lassen wir dann auch mal gut sein lassen
uns wahrscheinlich schon genug leute
wenn überhaupt dann geht ja hallo rego
bist du wirklich ist ich find dich und
deine videos so hart ich bin glaube ich
der größter fan
du bist doch auch von kopien oder ich
bin nie klar ich bin ein freund von der
kleinen schwester von krankhafter ja das
handy trucks lag auf dem tisch und ich
habe es mir einfach genommen weil ich
wusste dass hat eine nummer hat ist das
schlimm
ja ich wollte jetzt denn nummer
abspeichern
ich geb ich geb ich gib deine nummer
auch nicht weiter wenn du mich grüßt
kelly kelly ja richtig gut hält es tut
mir leid was ich es einfach mal machen
also ich mache also einen kleinen frank
kadic gut dort unbedingt auch bei ihr
sie vorbei ich verabschiede mich mal von
dir und beendet das video mir das war
die schwester von meiner freundin
ok dann mach's gut ist weil leute von
vier reingelegt das war hier haben
es war trotzdem richtig luca konntest du
dein styling und rede war auch voll
schwer okay leute
vielen dank an ally an der stelle das
auf jeden fall mal leichter wenn es euch
gefallen hat ich bin gerade selbst mega
hype dass und wie das funktioniert hat
weil sind einfach zwei leute drauf
reingefallen von 4 und ich stimme daraus
jetzt ein kleines video wenn ihr noch
mal ein teil zwei davon wollt dann lasst
mich gerne wissen wer jetzt noch dran
ist schreibt mal bitte telefonstreiche
in die kommentare ich verlinke euch hier
nochmal ein anderes video von mir und
den knopf zum abonnieren falls ihr lust
habt mich zu abonnieren
dann sehen wir beim nächsten mal wieder
und bis dahin tschüss